please welcome annette bening hello
everyone
from her very first moment in her very
first movie Lauren Bacall has been
nothing short of magic on the movie
screen in her debut performance an
apparently salivating movie critic for a
variety said of her she has an arresting
personality she can slink brother no
fooling it's a thrill for all of us to
be able to honor her tonight as woman of
the year as woman of every year she has
graced our lives with her fine work and
we are grateful to acknowledge her
ongoing legacy ladies and gentlemen
please join me in toasting the eternally
wonderful Lauren Bacall
now I have the honor of introducing a
colleague of Misbah calls they were
students together at the American
Academy of Dramatic Art in New York City
mr. Kirk Douglas
thank you Loen because became a famous
movie star when she tossed hungry bogus
House of whistles remember the scene
because standing and the doorway
look at Bogart see those were forced and
said Oh
how's the whistle just press your lips
together and blow
and and Bogart whistles loud and clear
and again they got married and they were
a wonderful couple
one night there was a formal dinner for
the Shah of Iran and they South were
dancing with be cold as they Kalev it
around Lulu he said to her mr. Cole you
are wonderful stencil and she will
reprise you bet your ass she imagines he
you